after the second world war the
Netherlands had to build a lot of new
houses not just to repair damage but to
handle the population from the post-war
Baby Boom under housing they built was
well it was pretty much all the same
most of it built quickly cheaply and one
of a few similar designs so in 1968 the
Dutch government's Ministry for public
housing and spatial planning started to
offer grants for experimental
architecture because to quote the
government minister in charge
you don't know what you're missing maybe
they'd find a way to radically improve
housing for everyone
a lot of the experiments were very tame
you wouldn't really notice them as you
walk through a city they just use
different materials or organize the
rooms or houses differently and they
actually did find ways to build better
homes
some of the experiments were the sort of
Stark brutalist work that you might
expect from 1960s or 70s Architects
interesting to look at not always great
places to live some of those became
quite famous like the cube houses in
helmond and Rotterdam one of the final
experiments to get the subsidy was built
in 1984 and it was very strange indeed
the bull running the sphere houses
sitting denbos in the south of the
country according to the designer artist
dries cry Camp humans were not meant to
live in a box it's not very spacious but
depending on the person like I
personally don't have glossophobia but I
have here it's from other people that
they have experiences close phobia when
they enter in the house so it's not made
for everyone cry Camp was more a
designer than an architect the
experimental houses are livable and
they're still used as social housing
where the local government is the
landlord but there are definitely some
problems because the trees the shell of
the house gets green pretty quickly it
wasn't five or ten years they do a
complete cleaning of the houses but
anything inside our house that's all for
yourself
except for proper maintains like the
boilers and that kind of stuff or if the
windows are leaking because that's one
of the biggest problems we have on a
good rainy day you can basically swim in
your living quarters the first floor is
when you enter the house the second
floor is the sleeping quarters they go
another stair and then you get to the
bathroom and the shower and then you
have the Upper Floor which is the living
room the kitchen if you have a lot of
stuff you have your job because there's
very limited room so you have to use
every inch even if you measure it's
still no guarantee that things will fit
the two halves of each house were built
in a temporary Factory on site here and
then connected together these are made
from glass fiber reinforced concrete
with 10 centimeters of rock wall
insulation between the outer and inner
hull which means they are warm if it's
thrown in degrees outside then it
becomes 25 insides so a week up into
Windows we're always looking forward to
the winter really during winter it's
quite nice and comfy actually like I
can't complain maybe if these plans
continue this third or fourth generation
of these houses would have worked well
but not only did they have problems they
also proved just too expensive compared
to the economies of scale for
traditional housing recently these
houses were added to Monumental status
so they get a little bit more care they
can't be demolished but that's only on
the local level not the governmental
level at least not yet the surprising
thing for me is not that these houses
exist there's a lot of weird houses out
there I've visited a few of them what
surprised me is they're still homes
they're still lived in they've not been
converged to hotels or short-term lets
or quirky tourist attractions and
they're not sitting disused and broken
the dreams of the Space Age didn't all
come to pass we don't all live in
spheres now and it turns out that there
are good reasons for that but
some people still do it's nice to live
here it's it's peaceful the shops are
nearby you gotta park next to your house
you can ice skate in the winter we have
good neighbors we do hang out with each
other with one another and you get used
to it it just ask a lot of adapting to
it and being creative